with andreas steven familia prokhalyog
from phd student of mine now working in
frankfurt with anthony mccormicker
um
a very classical setting in mathematical
population today is that of a
selective suite
so you might all know this and there are
several people in the audience who have
worked on this
um for example edison or rick or yorkin
have worked on this setting so it's very
simple
you assume that a beneficial mutant
arises a new beneficial mutant which is
very fit arises
in a population you condition it on
fixation and you can ask things about
for example
the probability of fixation
the time it takes until fixation given
fixates or you can
add another
neutral locus and ask for the
um
yeah
the pattern you see at this other
neutral lockers which then would call
genetic hitchhiking
so basically here in my graphs always
the time is running upwards
so i start with a frequency of zero here
with a frequency of one and you
basically start with seeing something
like an exponential growth of this thing
and then turns something into a logistic
and
yeah by just using
one dimensional diffusions in the
setting you can compute
that the time it takes for this highly
beneficial mutant to fixate is something
like two log alpha over alpha which i
chose here to write like this
alpha
ah sorry um alpha is the selection
coefficient so that's the scale
selection coefficient so s i would call
um in the right fischer model and two
and s is alpha m yeah thanks so
basically how do you understand this um
this result of this is two here
basically if you rescale time by alpha
over log alpha it takes just one unit of
time
until you hit some
yeah significant frequency five percent
or something it's very quick to go from
the one from epsilon to one minus
epsilon and then takes another log alpha
over alpha
um
time
which means another unit one in this
time scale to really go to fixation
and the question i'm going to ask in
this talk is well what happens if i'm in
a more realistic scenario which means
that i have a structured population
so all this
basically started
when wolfgang stefan
munich asked me this question well what
about selective sweeps
when the real population is structured
and here
yeah i started to think about this
essentially 10 years ago i think
the quest
the problem is
that
while
this
single beam case is quite simple and
you're losing a lot of techniques you
can use in the structured settings so
for example one-dimensional diffusions
that's very easy you can compute many
things with it
um
you can also say well i have a branching
process here or something and that can
still be used in the structured setting
but well this branching process somehow
then
this approximation doesn't work anymore
and when you get into higher frequencies
so in this setting and i also need a
migration rate which i will call mu in
this talk so i just have two parameters
now alpha the selection coefficient and
mu the migration rate
and just assume that this highly
beneficial mutant starts with this
one here so in my slides here b will
always be the beneficial mutant and w
will be the wild type so i just have two
alleles and two parameters here
um it starts here it increases in
frequency and at some point in time it's
exported to a second beam and then goes
to fixation
yes
so
well
as in the case of a single beam
i own i'm only interested in
beneficial mutants which really fixed in
the population so i condition my process
on fixation
and a first result
which is also very classical is
that the fixation probability only
depends on the sum
um of the frequency in all beams
and that's that leads to
the effect that when you write down in
this case of just two islands when you
write down a diffusion well what do you
get
you get something you will know you get
here
fluctuations of the order well
x which is the frequency of the
beneficial allele times the frequency of
the wild type
you get here a term for migration so it
shows here in this talk to use two
islands of the same
size so in the paper we have a little
bit a little bit more general and you
get this selection term here and here's
the term very condition
um on fixation so
that only depends on the sum of the two
which is a bit different than in the
last talk i think
and i'm going to explain to you today
basically this first result here
so let's just assume you have a certain
amount of migration mu which is not
small but also not too big it's
something proportional to alpha to the
power of p
so
still i mean alpha is going to infinity
in my um tohoku so mu is also a very
large number
so in the single dean case we had here a
two and now we have a three minus p
at least for p between zero and one so
it's a little bit longer that's not
surprising because it has to fix on both
islands
and well the question is how to
understand this really
and basically i'm going to explain to
you this picture
um
it starts
it takes off
and when you rescale time by alpha or
log arthur after time one minus p it's
exported to the second d
and then well it has to fix on the
second d and you know fixation on the
second beam takes well two units of time
so basically we have here after three
minus p we are done
the alien has fixed the population
okay this can be made more general i
mean when you look at this picture here
um
i'm basically saying after time one
minus p you the beneficial allele
infects a second d so if you think about
the case where you don't have just two
ions but just a graph
then after one minus p on this time
scale you just infect all neighbors
that's basically what it turns out to be
um
yeah
and
there's a second case maybe i'll come to
this at the end of my talk what's going
to be there so here
um
the migration to 8 is much slower much
much smaller so here
mu is going to infinity with alpha and
here mu is basically a small number
maybe constant or something
um
yeah well maybe the the main message in
this talk here is
even if migration is big so even if you
have something mute of the order alpha
to the p so that can be really big um
yeah it takes
a lot longer than under parmixia to fix
this one beneficial mutant
that's clear of course but when you
think about data analysis where people
just use the standard model of selective
sweeps it's not so clear um
yeah what would happen if they take the
structure of the population into account
arbitrary i mean we're just dealing with
finitely many islands
but that shouldn't restrict everything
too much
and in the paper we also have the case
where the islands can be of different
sizes which also doesn't change the
things too much
well when i started to think about this
question
the main problem was and the main
problem why i couldn't make progress for
a long time is i was just lacking a tool
because i have a multi-dimensional
diffusion process i would like to take
it very seriously that i have
constant population size and not using
branching processes to start with i mean
with branching processes
it would have been easier but i have
pretty constant population size
and the question is what are the tools
that you have
and i'm going to explain to you or
recall what the ancestral selection
graph was so that's basically
an extension of the usual kingman core
lessons
introduced in 97 by steve crown and
claudia neuhauser
and usually only used for small
selection straight
so let me just explain this to you
um so here's a
brand model with selection
i just have here very small population
size i start off with some beneficial
guys some wild type guys
and i have two kinds of resampling
events here so for example here this
wild type here produces offspring and
this one here is killed and you have an
offspring of this guy sitting here
that's the black hours arrows they are
really easy
but every line also creates
at rate alpha which is the selection
strength
these red arrows so what does what do
these red arrows mean
so they mean
only
if the yeah at the
back of the arrow there is a
beneficial guy
um only this guy can use the red arrow
for example when you consider this red
arrow here so here's the beneficial guy
well this one can use the red arrow and
place is another beneficial one here if
that here would have been a wild type it
couldn't have used the red arrow and
well there's no offspring sitting here
of the wildfire believe so that's the
moran model with selection and when you
consider
a large
moran model
um
yeah you have the parameter alpha n is
going to infinity then the frequency of
the beneficial alleles here converges to
the strategy differential equation which
i started with and that's not only true
in this case of a single island which i
draw here but also if i add migration
events um to the case with multiple
patterns
so what's the ancestral selection graph
then
as in the coalescent
are we not interested in the forwards
thing but in the backwards thing which
means you trace lines back in time and
for example when you consider these two
here
well you just see they call us by
this arrow here because well they just
have found their common ancestor
but the question is when you trace back
this line for example
and you don't know which type it is or
yet so you follow it back so you go here
and you hit this red arrow
but you just don't know if this one here
is beneficial or not or if uh
what was here but basically the question
is was this here beneficial or not you
don't know this yet so you just keep
track of both lines you just keep track
of both lines
you do this from the top to the bottom
then you decide well which line carries
which allele and then you go up again
and then you know it was this beneficial
or not and if it was then this arrow
here can be used
so
basically you get a graph like this here
you start with for example
yeah
two lines they call less as usual in the
coalescent but at rate alpha they
produce here a split and you have a
continuing line and an incoming line
that's what
um
conan neuhauser called it
um
while you do this i have here just two
coalescence event and two splitting
events
and then i decide well
what's on the bottom for example if i
have two wire types here because i have
no mutation or anything it's clear that
it must have two wild types at the top
and let me also point out so well what
is what is this graph about it's about
potential ancestors so i have all the
potential answers this year
for example also if i have to be a
little
at the bottom i will have two b alleles
at the top it's also clear
and the interesting cases are if i only
have one beneficial allele here and one
wild type here so what would happen
so this beneficial allele here could use
this
what what was a red arrow in the ram
model so this one here
is beneficial
this one here is wild type the water is
inherited here
yeah this area here cannot be used by
the wild type because it's an incoming
line but this one here was beneficial so
well i end up having two beneficial
lines
and the same if i change this around if
this one here is beneficial the wild
type cannot use this arrow the only
ancestor which is left is the beneficial
allele which inherits its type to the
top so basically what this amounts to
when you look at this
um
well
just look at this here this one is
beneficial if and only if
any possible or if only if there is one
ancestor
at the bottom which was beneficial
so this one here has two potential
ancestors which is this one this one
and it's beneficial if and only if one
of these two here is beneficial
well
um
exactly so
yeah
recall we are in the structured suite
case so i just explained to you the
ancestral selection graph
in a penmitty case but that can easily
be
also made to a structured population
so how do you see
in the accessory selection graph
this kind of picture so when it is
supported here and everything else
so that's the question now
and of course when you think
about this okay these here these lines
are current rate alpha
and
well it's when you start to think about
this
if alpha is small okay you say well
that's just a small perturbation of your
coalescence you can do something
but i'm having alpha large so alpha
large turns out to be also quite nice
for some reasons
there is a basic thing i would like to
explain to you so how can i study
fixation in this ancestral selection
graph
and
well as follows
start the ancestral section graph with
infinitely many lines in all beams
you do the ancestral selection graph for
some time t
you mark a single line
at the bottom
and if this single line was an ancestor
of all the infinite main lines you had
then the allele has fixated so just in
the picture
so well it's not infinitely many but
it's very many i have here
i follow these lines
back to the bottom
i mark a single line
as beneficial
and then i see how this thing here
spreads and if i reach all of them the
allele has fixated so that's the basic
idea
and that's what this lemma here was
saying
okay
i have a limit epsilon to zero here
which means i have a very small
number of
beneficial leads to start with which
means i only
mark one of them here
but
well i started with many lines but not
with infinitely many here in this
picture and that's
maybe a problem i don't know
i would like to extend this picture a
bit i like to use two more properties of
the ancestral selection graph
i said
i have alpha large
and let's just
do a quick computation how many lines i
would have in equilibrium for this
ancestral selection graph so basically
what the ancestralization graph does it
says it has coalescence
which is basically quadratic rate
and it has linear increase so alpha
times k is the rate of going up and k
choose 2 is the rate of going down so
basically in equilibrium you have two
alpha lines so that's what you have and
alpha is large so you have many lines
which is close to infinity mean lines
so maybe it's okay to start in
equilibrium and not really use infinity
mean lines it turns out to be yes
you can do this start in equilibrium
and another thing which is immediately
clear in the panicky case and can also
be shown to
be the case in the structured setting is
well it's just a birth death process and
both that processes are well known to be
reversible
so you don't only can use this picture
well top to bottom mark one and then
bottom to top but you can immediately
start at the bottom and construct this
picture here in equilibrium from bottom
to top which is very nice
so these are these are basically the two
properties i will use
okay in the structure population it's
you have to do one computation and you
see well
the reverse reversibility also holds in
the structured setting so that's nice
and it also holds on the level of the
graph really not only on counting lines
that's the computation you have to do
but when you do this well basically
you have a very nice tool in the
structured case
so this was here what i just explained
to you
the equilibrium
you can compute the equilibrium uh the
reversal reversible equilibrium of the
ancestral selection graph which is
basically well
um
you take a poisson random variable you
condition it to be positive
with this parameter and yeah there you
get a certain number of lines and you
just distribute them equally on all the
demons so this is the reversible
algorithm for your ancestral section
graph in the structured population
um
well
and then there was this thing
not starting with infinitely many lines
but just with very many lines
so that's not a big problem because you
know
already the coalescence comes down from
infinitely many lines to two alpha lines
at a time one over alpha which is small
compared to log alpha over alpha which
is the scale i'm using here so that's
also no problem
okay so again well
in principle i would have this number of
lines
the direction of time doesn't matter
upwards or downwards because well it's
reversible
and here's the picture from before
so i will just use
at the bottom
this poisson equilibrium mark one and
see how this spreads through all of them
and when i reached all of them and
everything is fine
and
well
just consider this one line what i start
with
what does it do
well
everything is exchangeable so this guy
here splits at rate alpha because that's
the property of the ancestral selection
graph and it coalesces with others at
rate one basically
but when you just consider
the yeah the colored lines here
at the start it just makes a huge
process because it just splits just
splits it rate alpha
that's basically also an approximation
which the red and schweinsberg worked
out some years ago
then you can use this yule process
approximation
of course you can argue well basically
that's a branching process approach but
here we still have the full model and we
also can control the error we're doing
another thing that will also be
helpful here is what happens at the very
end
you consider
the non-colored things and you can see
basically what they're doing they're
doing a sub-critical branching process
and
you can compute easily how long it takes
until the sub-critical branching process
dies out
and that's the other thing
okay
so in a single beam it's now
relatively easy to compute the
fixation time
um
yeah
so using
the picture from the bottom to the top
um
yeah
so
how long does this yield process
approach work
well it basically works until you have
alpha to some power which is smaller
than one copies of the beneficial allele
that's how long this will work
and
well if you have only
alpha to the one minus epsilon of the
w's then this makes this up really the
branching process and you can study this
and as we saw already well what happens
in between so this here the b has such
many copies and the w has such many
copies that's just fast what happens in
between that's just fast
that only takes yeah time one over alpha
basically
um so the single dean we understand
everything basically
but what happens now
um in the structured case and the only
thing we have to understand still
is
the export of the sweep to the second d
that's what we have to understand
so
well when is this so we assume here
that migration rate is alpha to the
power of p
um when does the first migrant in the
ancestral selection graph occur from
beam 1 to d2 and that's easy to answer
well
first of all
not before this time i would say
because so what's this time here so if
you consider a yule process that's the
time a yule process needs to go from one
line
to
um
yeah to the
alpha to the power one minus p minus
epsilon lines so that's this time here
and if you just compute the expected
number of migration events on this yule
process so you mark a dual process
at rate alpha to the p
you wait until the use process has alpha
to the one minus p minus epsilon lines
and how many will you see well
on average that's easy to compute
because well that's the time the yield
process takes with i lines the rate is
alpha times mu you sum all these
what you end up with is basically alpha
to the p from the mu after the one minus
p divided by alpha and the small minus
epsilon stays also here so this goes to
zero so it's not before this time here
not before this time
and it's also certainly
the first mark is not after this time
because
when you add epsilon here because when
you do the same calculation you add
epsilon here well the expected number of
migration marks on the sealed process is
going to infinity so it must be in the
limit basically at time one minus p on
this time scale alpha of log alpha
so that's what we have and that's
exactly essentially what was also the
picture so after this time of order one
minus p um the sweep was exported
okay
so basically this explains here again
this picture what i already had well
after time one minus p it's exported to
the second dean okay i explained
everything now in the ancestral
selection graph but basically
you understand that this very much maps
to the original process because
um
it has very similar properties
and then it takes another
two units of time until fixation
well that's basically what i wanted to
explain today just to summarize
um
well
in the general setting when you have
more deems you just have to infect them
again
and let me also try to explain to you
what happens in the other case when you
have small migration rates
maybe here
when you have small migration rates so
if the migration rate is off the order
one over log alpha so what happens then
basically you first need to weight one
unit of time because at one unit of time
you know that here the ancestor
selection graph has off the order alpha
or two alpha even beneficial lines in
this one d
and yeah you have this
rescaling of time by log alpha and if
migration is also v out of one over log
alpha well it's just a random
exponentially distributed time until the
first migrant comes if
use of the order one over log alpha so
that's the reason here
um for this
um
yeah for this
s
that here um which was basically
an exponential distributed time here
um
in the case of two islands um so first
one unit of time in the first team then
x to export the team and then another
two time units to fix on the second team
so that's what this amounts to
um
well and basically
yeah that's what i wanted to say what we
still have to do of course
is well maybe extend the success
reflection graph idea to also include
recombination
because that's something we didn't do
yet so include
not only selection but also
recombination
we would then have an ancestral
recombination and selection graph and
that's helpful then in order to study
really genetic hitchhiking where you
also study what happens at a neutral
locus which is connected to this
beneficial allele but that's something
we will do in the future okay
in the thanks
uh yeah the one thing i was wondering
about i would
expect like usually the second sweep to
be
faster in the first maybe because you
sort of get in an influx of mutation
from the
worst population is this not the case
um
very good question yeah i mean when you
work out these equations here um you
have
the sweep export to the second beam
okay it grows they are already at speed
alpha but migrants from the other team
come at slower rate because it's still
in the the first theme has only alpha to
this thing here so it's still a bit
smaller what comes from the first theme
so basically in this setting we now have
we will see a single origin as a single
migrant in every beam
so first question
so this is an asymptotics of course for
large alpha right yeah um does it ex
describe you know alpha of 1000
pretty well also if you do simulations
when you do simulations um
yeah the the question is what's the
error yeah yeah i mean we did
simulations alpha 1000
um i mean it also depends on really what
the p is then
um
because for larger p might be better
than for smaller p
but that turned out to be quite good
um
yeah
i mean downside of this approach is you
cannot really control the arrow because
you just
well
you just have limit results and no error
terms essentially that's something we
cannot deal with
one over log
at
alpha
i mean the red and schweinsberg show
that this yule process idea produces an
error of order one or log alpha square
and we also have this yield process
implicit here
so uh maybe it's also one over like
alpha square
but i kind of show this yeah
maybe this is equivalent to what you're
doing but it's what does that with large
alpha if one does the branching process
analysis yeah to get you up to some
value
the media value and then splices onto
the the diminished behavior and splices
back on again that you can do
systematically with corrections
sure you can do this i mean you can't
prove it but you can do that
exactly
i agree yeah
first of all you have to
understand
so when you do this first branching then
the domestic then branching again so
what's the error of this
how large is the arrow
it's one overlook alpha i think
yeah but you can do the correct you can
do the correction
but the arrow is one overlook alpha
of the model that you described which is
the approximate model yeah so you cannot
be better than this
no because you can
you start with that as your as your
basic point and then you do you
drastically get the corrections factor
the one exit exactly right
exactly but how
one of the errors comes from the initial
branching virus that's
yeah the only error is in matching
splices associated with matching that in
the astronautic uh
regime which i would have actually some
of the
rejections right because
after some time the bride project grows
and it's deterministic up to just
the honest to kiss this useless origin
with that exponential
because the errors in the model
have been much worse than the
errors you're going to get from any
questions
well i mean it's a general comment about
it right
which things are worth really pushing
yeah which is pushing through the ones
that have a lot of generality to them
that don't depend upon what we deal with
yeah i mean already you know the fact
that 2s is sort of a religious thing
yeah and constant population size
is a very important thing yeah
so
but a lot of these features are very
very general the advantage of sort of
doing it with transport and splicing is
you see all the general structure
right away
when you are writing down the model
which is
assuming that alpha is order one and
then letting alpha get very large so one
has to question whether it's going
through
inhaling
graph right so
so what dan's proposing is doing
the forward calculation which is
probably which may in the situation
actually be easier i think it's probably
harder to control the errors than the
ancestral
well maybe true for the moran model
for the diffusion i wouldn't really know
yeah
well wait what what may be true for them
i mean
the random model is a discrete model so
you can just use a discrete branching
process to approximate the initial phase
in the end phase right
um
for the diffusion i don't know
if it's that easy
for the diffusion model
what it means it's a difference
in diffusion
i mean there are two limits
as their limits population is going to
infinity and alpha goes to infinity and
i take the limit first and goes to
infinity and then also goes to infinity
you might be able to do something
clever
anything which depends when it's
detailed doesn't matter
um are there any questions not to do
with log alphabet
when you basically just
with
broke
up
of initiative order one in the warrant
process you're basically somebody
you're still going to get the same sort
of quality structure on that and so it
seems to be like passing a division and
there's a whole bunch of unnecessary
complexity when you just directly do
discrete objects
i mean i would rather argue the
diffusion is the limit of many processes
so it's maybe better to use this
and the mirand model gets much
complexity because well
when something splits it might come from
a line which was already in the graph
and you have to take this into account
that's not really fun
so did i understand this rightly that a
migration among all these teams is of
the same order yes
so then obvious question is can you go
on to real stepping stone right so
where you have like a zero migration
from one team to the
uh
too many others right so yeah it's a
real spatial structure
now i did have real space structure
um i just assumed that the order of the
migration rate is the same for all
connections
but these can be just only nearest
neighbor connections yeah well yes
it's a graphic graph you only have huge
neighbors i mean
connection means neighbor i mean you
could also ask
um if the migration rate is different
for different connections what happens
then that would be a valid question
and we haven't really thought about this
actually but you have that sy in there
so you you can yeah you have distances
yeah yeah
and then you get regimes like what oscar
was
talking about yesterday once you
you know come to different ranges and
then yeah
process
yeah okay but you're gonna get you can
splice this onto that yeah yeah and your
problem so the one
yeah
okay any further questions
in which case
that's
just watching the virtual also
perform
why
turn off your mobile phones and finish
your breakfast and have some cup of
coffee outside
let's thank peter again